and somehow the question is do I do the
whole review with the dragon on my
shoulder or or just the intro I love you
bud you just a little distracting
so how to train your dragon the hidden
world the conclusion to be How to Train
Your Dragon franchise and that's very
much a definitive conclusion I have to
say and I'm not sure that's really too
much of a spoiler basically all the
marketing has made it very clear this is
it for this thing and I went into this
with a lot of hope and a lot of fear
because I have immense affection for
this series the first two films I
absolutely adore I've seen a little bit
the TV show it looked pretty good but I
haven't had the time to really dig into
it and honestly but the graphical
downgrade does kind of eat at me because
I have the movies as a point of
reference I had the same problem trying
to get into the Kung Fu Panda TV stuff
but I've heard from other folks that
that's actually quite good but I I adore
these films I think they are phenomenal
and wrapping everything up was not going
to be an easy thing because these have
not only been beautiful films with great
characters and terrific relationships
between them but they have had really
strong core emotional journeys that have
largely had to do with growing up and I
was afraid that I don't know why I was
afraid of this but I was afraid that the
film was gonna lose that thread a bit
now that spoiler for the second one I
guess now that hiccups dad is gone now
that Stoics dead so I went into this
just hoping to god they nailed the
emotional core of this and they did
for the record in case anyone as
wondering 3 that's how many times I
cried during this movie it is worth
noting that it was back loaded all three
others happened probably within the last
10 to 15 minutes of the film um maybe
the last 20 but it was pretty much
condensed at the back end so the setup
is a pretty straight continuation from
the previous film they the residents of
Berk are continuing to you know work to
fight against and free dragons from
trappers who are trying to get them get
them total warlords who want to use them
as weapons and they've been doing this
for a while actually to the point that
Berk is now almost completely over one
run with dragons and like they really
can't fit anymore
where they are and now there is a new
foe in the form of a guy named grim old
who is basically a dragon killer he's
not a trapper he's not a trainer he's a
killer and he's been brought in by the
Warlord's to take out specifically
toothless because apparently this guy
really has a has a real keen thing for
night Furies as a target and as this is
going on we also and this isn't a sport
this this actually turned out to be way
less of a spoiler than I thought it was
going to be because she gets introduced
almost immediately which is a female
Night Fury
but is all-white it gets referred to as
the light fury here and so toothless is
trying to figure out how to impress her
and there's a lot of dialog free bonding
between the two of them that's really
well done
sometimes played for laughs other times
play for motion all of it works you know
very much like how the best moment of
bonding in that first film was a
wordless sequence of toothless trying to
imitate hiccup you know scratching out
an image in the sand
the this is able to pick up that sort of
mantle in terms of delivering dialogue
free bonding between toothless and the
light fury and so all this is is going
out at the same time and that and this
is this sort of culminates in our finale
in our and our climax I don't think I'll
have to talk too much about the very end
it's still fairly reason I prefer not to
get into spoilers when I say I cried at
the end I it was the good kind of crying
yeah that's sort of it's the kind of
crying this series makes me do that you
know you're tearing up with your also
like yeah that that that's the kind of
crying this movie gets out of me
so as I said I was a little bit nervous
about the continuation of hiccups a
story in particular because well I'm not
necessarily gonna go so far as to say
the relationship between stoic and
hiccup was the absolute core of the
films that relationship was very much
emblematic of hiccups growth and it was
a big part of why I and I feel like I
can sort of sum up a lot of what works
about both films in that relationship so
I was afraid to have it gone what I mean
by that is the first film a while there
is you know sort of finding someone that
you bond with that he that hiccup has
with toothless ultimately it is about
you know finding your place possibly
even in defiance of those around you and
it's about learning how to stand your
ground
even against someone you love which
hiccup has to do now the second film and
I I honestly really love this is sort of
the next phase of growing up which is
realizing that you even if you've had
some breakthroughs before you don't know
everything and sometimes the people
older than you actually do know more
than you do because when stoic tells
hiccup in that second film that you
cannot reason with somebody like drago
bludvist that you know you have to just
fight him in and hiccup says no I can I
can
talk to him I can I can make him
understand the way I made you understand
and hiccups wrong he's absolutely wrong
and it was important for him to learn
that it's like just because something
worked once doesn't mean you can keep
falling back to that you have to
sometimes understand that you don't know
everything and not only did hiccup have
to learn that he learned that at the
cost of his father's life ultimately and
so I worried without stoical there
although we get him in some flashbacks
that it was gonna lose the thread and
where it ultimately kind of ends up
going with it is it basically puts
hiccup in the parent role because the
dynamic between him and hiccup Wow still
very much
friends becomes a bit more of a
parent-child dynamic when toothless
starts courting belite fury because now
hiccup has to contend with the idea that
toothless might have a different or
better life without him and he has to
learn to let him go very much in the way
that a parent has to learn to let go of
their child when they go out and you
know make it on their own and when I
realized that that was what the film was
doing initially I I kind of cringe I was
like oh God has the film earned that and
it did it did initially I was nervous
but it does it does tackle in such a way
that doesn't feel like a ham-fisted
transition of you know hiccups overall
journey going from you know young adult
adult a parent effectively as far as the
dine at his primary dynamic and and
where he's learning his life lessons go
that was that did actually work as a
total final progression and also we're
getting to see him actively be the the
leader of the Berk and like actually
have to make big decisions and convince
people to follow him which is actually
kind of nice since usually a protagonist
and these things tend to be
against the authority so for him to
actually be the authority in Burke at
the very least that works quite well and
and emotionally this thing is just
wonderful it's and it's visually gourd
lit gorgeous if you could see it in 3d
please do because the flight sequences
are stunning as they always have been
the actions really good
the dragons are are cool and silly
sometimes and fun and scary some of them
we got some new ones introduced in this
and this one some of them are are quite
intimidating it's just really it's a
really good film if I have to nitpick
and I do because it's me and if you
didn't realize that I was going to do
this hey welcome to the channel there
are a few things that aren't quite
clicking one is something that is not a
complete detriment and actually neither
is but one annoyed me more than the
other the first thing is the villain and
this case we have F Murray Abraham doing
his best Dracula impression as grim old
and grim Walt is a functional villain
now to be fair villains have never
really been the you know the big driving
force of these stories which is fun
because the the driving force is
whatever dynamic or growth or lesson
hiccup himself is learning through his
relationships with toothless his father
learning to let go toothless now and
this one so it doesn't necessarily need
the world's best villain but even
compared to the last films one with with
Drago grimille feels just kind of like a
bit of a step down because Drago
especially by the end of that film you
realized was kind of almost a Dark
Mirror - hiccup he was what hiccup could
have been under worse circumstances
whereas Grimmauld is just kind of a jerk
and he's actually not even that good at
what he does so like he gets a leg up on
on our heroes in the latter stretch of
the
film but not because he's smart or
clever but because somebody else was an
idiot and it just makes him less
impressive and intimidating as a villain
again he's functional he works and in
terms of pushing that element of the
plot giving them someone who's pursuing
them coming after them who is a
legitimate danger he's not he's not
unthreatening but he's just kind of
there so that's one thing the other and
this one bothered me a bit more is
honestly most of the supporting cast
does not have very much to do and
thinking back on it that's actually been
true for at least some of these
characters for at least two films now so
like honestly most of the supporting
cast doesn't have a lot to do Astrid is
mainly there just to be hiccups moral
support
Valka that's hiccups mother again
spoiler for the second one I suppose she
is she doesn't get any particular
highlight moments but I mean she also
doesn't feel out of place or shoehorned
in however
the other characters who had been
introduced way back in the first film as
the other P as the other Vikings in
dragon training yeah they feel really
shoehorned in and unnecessary and like
the film just does not know what to do
with them anymore so this is fishlegs
snotlout
ruffnut and tuffnut the those for the
film just does not know what to do with
them which would have been fine if it
was prepared to write them to just
relegate them to the background and
leave it at that but unfortunately it
keeps giving them scenes and the scenes
feel awkward and don't and repetitive
and don't move anything forward and
you're like why are why are we still
dealing with these guys why aren't they
just like at the front of a crowd shot
now these characters are not the only
ones that that feel like KY not really
all that contributing too much I mean
Eric Summit son of eret okay
Harrington's character he's back and he
doesn't have a heck of a lot to do but
he just feels like he's been integrated
into the site and society the film
doesn't try and highlight him and shove
him into into extra-time the way it does
with with these other four it's and it's
just kind of unfortunate that time gets
eaten with these with these characters
um I don't want to make it sound like
none of the supporting characters work
gobber is still great and actually they
get there anyone who's paid attention to
the behind the scenes in what was said
by the filmmakers about Gobber after the
second one while it is not made explicit
in this film I would have liked it it's
not there are some if you pay attention
there are some really really clear
indications confirming what it was that
the at the filmmakers said about it oh
heck I'll just say it so the filmmakers
after the first one said they'll
gobber's gay and again while it's not
explicit in this one there's a couple of
lines and a couple of moments where it's
like yeah not like he's suddenly
effeminate but just like little lines
you're like mmm and actually I think he
and Aaron are a couple or at the very
least it's starting I don't think I'm
crazy if you haven't seen the movie yet
or if you're gonna see it a second time
pay attention to the two of them yeah I
think so
I think that I think I want to wrap it
up about there on a more on a more
positive note because I did my
nitpicking but this was this was really
good if I we're gonna do the whole thing
honestly the this is probably gonna be
the least of the three but again that's
not because it's bad and it's certainly
it sticks the landing and it sticks it
hard in the best possible way but
ultimately if I were to compare all the
component parts and the the fullness of
the journey to get to that really
phenomenal ending I think the other
films are stronger throughout their
runtime as a
to sort of their strengths being back
loaded the way this one is but this was
still a really good really good film it
was a good time at the movies it was
touching if you care about these
characters you owe it to yourself to go
and see this How to Train Your Dragon
the hidden world and and yeah I will
point out it does bug me that it makes
for a very awkward sort of sequel hidden
you know how to train a dragon one and
two and hidden world okay you know pick
pick a naming convention and stick with
it anyways have you seen it what are
your thoughts on it whatever they are
just drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
to do buttons links patreon P o box it's
my birthday this month either one of
those would make a great present I'd
appreciate it other leads to check out
besides give them a look or don't it's
okay because at the end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]